Hello Freak bitches,
and and the thing is there's this
illusion of stability.
There's the solution that because the
system is so big,
it can't possibly be for your child,
but the truth is exactly the opposite.
It has become incredibly fragile.
It is extremely overextended and
extremely fragile,
and you see the,
the Federal Reserve at the moment has
been pumping money into the economy like
crazy for five years and as they do
that,
you get diminishing returns,
so every here they put the same amount
of money in and they,
they move the economy,
they moved the stock market a bit less
and then they put more money in and it
moves a bit lesson until they're putting
money in just to keep it stable.
Now I've seen that pattern before.
I mean that looks like a cocaine habit
right
in the first year,
right?
The coke addict is snorting a lot of
free Federal Reserve money and the stock
market's getting really high.
Indeed's bye bye.
Here.
Five it takes.
It takes a big fat line of Federal
Reserve money just just to keep the
stock market from crashing in the
morning.
And then one day which happened in mid
October,
the Federal Reserve turned off the tap a
month ago.
Federal Reserve stopped giving out free
money to the banks.
We haven't seen the effect that will
have in the stock market,
but if you follow your cocaine addict
analysis
right now,
that addict is Jonesing for a hit and is
really,
really cranky.
Some bad things could happen.
But yeah,
there are about seven to eight months
away from sucking trucker dicks.
And that's really what's going on.
I mean,
there are about.
They're about that far away.
There's a lot of people like super
pumped up to start a revolution.
They're walking into trader Joe's,
clapping their hands saying,
you can't stop the revolution.
Have you seen this?
It's fucking videos of these morons.
And it's usually like menopausal women
dudes with aimless shiftless minds.
You know,
people that there's something wrong with
them.
They're out there walking through
supermarkets yelling at people,
people just trying.
And you can't stop the revolution.
It's like,
what revolution is this?
The revolution that interrupts shopping
with shitty singing revolution
can have affordable yogurt and fresh
fruits,
privileges.
It's this thing of doing nothing but
making a lot of energy and sound by
doing it.
Like I get that you're upset about
police brutality.
I get that you're upset about the way
this country's going.
I get the.
But going through trader Joe's,
clapping your hands is in fixing a
fucking thing because just going to
alienate people to whatever dumb idea
you have.
Yeah.
Uh,
there was a woman in Venice beach who
came up to me recently and asked me to
sign our petition to run for president.
She's gonna run.
Yeah.
I was Kinda like,
well,
don't you maybe you want to start with
like a youtube channel or something
like,
who the fuck are you,
you know,
you can't just leap right to president.
And she had a few signatures and was so
serious about it.
And I was like,
well,
what's the platform?
And she's like,
we're going to eliminate homelessness in
Venice beach.
And I was thinking like,
that's not really a national platform,
you know,
you're gonna become president and be
like,
we have to address the five homeless
people right here.
So,
um,
my point though is I think that people
think that they have to change something
and they have to do something because
they can see all the problems around
them.
And for some people that's let's go to a
protest or let's,
let's run for office or let's,
you know,
let's just start a petition no matter
how ridiculous it sounds.
And the sad reality is revolution is
silent nowadays.
Like the people who are online buying
bitcoin and developing these other coins
are creating more of a revolution than
anybody in the trader Joe's on a
Tuesday.
But I feel like that's the type of shit
that like when you almost start dressing
like a chick,
like you actually get more pussy,
like more women coming in.
Like that rock star thing that in,
in this fucking lucky you start
borrowing their clothes and next ain't
no,
they're blowing you.
Once I heard it went well.
What's really funny is that an hit
parade is pretty.
Like Judas priest started a lot of the
metal stuff.
Rob Halford,
snm dressing,
snam dressing and people didn't realize
he was gay as fuck right here.
I had no idea rob hoffer was gay as
fuck,
and he got all these guys to essentially
dress like gay s and m guys.
Yeah.
That was what became the look is
brilliant,
but that's so much of a bad
motherfucker.
He is.
He made
one of the great front man and then
nothing too he.
He basically was completely 100 percent
other than Freddie mercury who was
literally in a band called Queen
at.
We're just so dumb,
like,
no,
he's fine.
He's straight.
He seems good.
That's all.
Don't be homophobic
like it matters.
Yeah.
To tie to mercury.
I made that fucking guy that,
that live aid set is one of the.
I would put that up against anybody's
performance ever.
Well,
who's a bad motherfucker?
He turned Wembley Stadium into a fucking
coffee house.
He had them.
Everybody like the fucking back row
[inaudible].
That guy was unbelievable.
Yeah,
he was sensational.
He was a really unique talent.
Like there was no one like him before
because he was such a combination of
like masculinity and femininity and I
never noticed any of that.
I was just like,
this fucking guy.
He can't stop watching them,
but his,
his,
uh,
his singing was credible and he was a
better,
live as good as the albums where he's
one of the few guys that was actually
fucking better live.
Wow.
I haven't seen anybody come close to
that guy.
Wow.
Since,
wow.
That's a strong bill.
Burr.
Anybody.
You got anybody that could fuck fucking
hold 100,000 people in the palm of his
hand after he had to follow all those
other base.
You know,
it's true.
You have to go on after Robert Plant
Jimmy page.
That one didn't go well.
That was what.
That was one of the ones that didn't go
out,
which is why 2007 went so well because
they were like,
we can't do that again.
They put it together the last fucking
second.
And then he had bad.
They had to dramas at the saint.
Can you please whisper in my ear during
my accident?